sad news from h.wood you guys taiga has
given up hope ever reuniting what with
Kylie Jenner
I know calm down
oh good you are well you see one thing
happens you become a dad is that you see
it's giving a about celebrities and
so comedians I'm going to show you a
current popular celebrity and I want you
to tell me who an out-of-touch dad
thinks it is let's start with an easy
one who who's this flame fantastic Sam
ah very good boy I did it myself haha
gotta be the hair I don't know who she
is but she's ha except this sultry come
on with this Wayne Brady
my next restraining order ah
there goes their stuff this is charcoal
reenactor oh hey yes Wayne isn't here he
just a bill just the normal sitting here
on Capitol Hill I really you know what I
want to give a shout out to Lynn because
Lynn gave me a job with jasmine is
playing burr in the Chicago Hamilton man
fantastic I loved it in the Partridge
Family it was not in the Partridge
Family what about his opto I know okay
yeah except this demure young lass yes
that is Trump's next Supreme Court
nominee all right boy
[Applause]